un regard dans un jardin c'est la
proposition du département pour la nuit
européenne des musées et visiteurs ont
été accueillis aux portes du muséum
d'histoire naturelle par un spécimen
reconstitués d'après les mensurations
exacte d'un requin pêché
accidentellement dans les eaux de
l'océan indien
j'ai réussi à voir les mensurations du
requin par université
par la suite il fait une maquette à
l'échelle 1 7e en pâte à modeler qui
était validée par les scientifiques de
dégâts si tu es donc après j'ai fait
zéro construire aucun l'échelle 1 donc
j'ai fais profil en bois là dessus j'ai
collé des dunes la mouche bleue ritan en
pans de mousse café pendant deux mois
j'ai sculpté à la main les forums exact
turquin un grand requin blanc celui ci
qui empêchent beaucoup d'autres c'est à
l'intérieur du musée que le spectacle
continue pour les amateurs de sensations
fortes
le rendez vous avec l'exposition rouquin
plonger les visiteurs à cent mille
lieues sous les mers pour mieux cerner
les différentes espèces de squales qui
habitent nos océans
visite guidée de l'exposition requins
qui est une exposition assez complète à
la fois sur les relations entre le
requin et son milieu et les relations
entre l'homme et le requin comment elle
et la mâchoire
elle a toutes petites gens plein de
petites dents au dessus et en bas la
nuit au musée c'est une vraie découverte
pour les petits mais également pour les
plus grands j'ai toujours passer devant
mais je ne suis jamais rentré à
l'intérieur et je trouve que
dans l'exposition que l'architecturé du
lieu est très sympa c'est une découverte
oui déjà m'est venue non alors de ce que
tu avoueras qu'est ce que je fais ça
intéressant la wii la petite qui
voulaient venir sa famille
et une fois j'ai quand j'étais petit je
suis venu avec le temps j'ai des goûts
tout une nuit des musées est placée sous
le signe du bleu de l'océan mais aussi
une nuit du musée qui nous emmène à la
découverte des autres formes d'art des
plus anciennes aux plus contemporaines
c'est aussi ça la magie de la culture le
département possède plusieurs musées et
conserve le patrimoine de la réunion
donc on est ici au musée d'histoire
naturelle
mais il ya aussi le musée léon dierx on
va aller par la suite au lazaret lieu de
débarquement et on va aller aussi à
villèle il ya un patrimoine du conseil
départemental qui demande à être encore
plus connue des réunionnais et la nuit
des musées c'est toutes les portes de
ses musées qui sont ouverts gratuitement
au public réunionnais et du jardin de
l'état qui abrite le musée d'histoire
naturelle au musée léon dierx il n'y a
que quelques pas à faire dans la
fraîcheur de la nuit dionysienne que de
nombreuses personnes n'ont pas hésité à
faire ici c'est le travail de jeunes
enfants issus des écoles de l'île qui
est mise à jour les idées sont venues
des enfants donc des projets très variés
photographie projet un plastique de
production plastique projet de film et à
partir de là on est revenu vers une
autre visite pour retravailler sur
l'oeuvre qu'on avait choisi parce que
les enfants étaient les médiateurs ce
soir d'une oeuvre qu'ils ont présenté
avec l'introduction de la psychose des
travaux d'enfants qui inventent qui
créent et qui s'inspire de l'univers
daniel ferrand une restitution qui
s'imbriquent dans l'espace d'un musée
qui ouvre ses coulisses qui montre
l'envers du décor pour que l'envers pour
une fois soit lui aussi dans la lumière
le musée propose aussi aux visiteurs à
une petite exposition sera finalement
les coulisses du musée c'est qu'on a
montré une partie des acquisitions qui
ont été faites y à peu près une centaine
d'oeuvres ont été achetés c'est 5 6 8 et
anan est depuis 2008
on montre aussi on a fait un petit film
on a montré les derniers tableaux qui
ont été restaurés depuis 2012 de
partenariat qu'on a fait avec l'institut
national du patrimoine permettre à tous
de voir et de se nourrir de notre
culture notre patrimoine faute de le
toucher des yeux pourquoi ne pas le
toucher des doigts et ce sont les
nouvelles technologies et la magie de
l'icône au tec qui nous offre ce retour
dans le futur on propose l'espace
virtuel du musée c'est à dire que la
continuité en fait des expositions
temporaires que l'on peut retrouver
notamment sur les sites de l'icône
hawtai qui donne une seconde vie aussi
bien sûr cela ne remplace en aucun cas
des oeuvres originales
dans lesquels on doit envisager la
conservation préventive la restauration
bien évidemment mais c'est un moyen de
faire connaître c'est un moyen de
démocratiser l'accès au patrimoine est
encore assoiffés on se faufile par le
petit chemin qui mène de l'autre côté du
côté de l'ars qui peut surprendre mais
qui imagine les choses autrement
l'artothèque fait aussi son spectacle
avec 25 artistes qui confrontent leurs
regards
pour cette douzième édition de la nuit
des musées et musées départementaux ont
rassemblé plus de 3700 visiteurs